in the interactive thriller 12 minutes
you play as a man who becomes trapped in
a time loop replaying the same 12
minutes
of one fateful evening in his apartment
over and over again
each time you're going to have the
chance to make new choices learn what
led up to those terrible events and
perhaps even escape them
it's a story that's not just about how
choices matter but
about how some stories can only truly be
told when they can change
even just a little bit every single time
you tell them
it was a joy to participate in this
project and lend my voice to the main
character and i hope you have as much
fun playing it as i did making it
i am very proud to introduce a game
where the end is only the beginning
12 minutes
i have a surprise for you okay
you want to guess what it is this is an
outfit for a newborn
you bought it this morning you wanted to
surprise me
i'm sorry you're pregnant you know
i know because you already gave it to me
this has happened before what are you
talking about
what's going on someone is coming he's
going to hurt us
he says you killed your father i need to
know what happened
why are you doing this my father died of
a heart attack
no i i i didn't have anything to do with
any second now he's gonna knock on that
door help me
this isn't happening this can't be
happening
please open up
my name is luis i'm the creator of 12
minutes
i grew up watching a lot of film they
always captivated me and i
tried to understand what were they doing
the the pacing the colors the lighting
the composition
in order to to create these emotions
[Music]
what are the tools we have as game
designers that allow us to do similar
things
i think the biggest challenge is that
usually when you think about narrative
we think about a linear progression in
an interactive game
at least in 12 minutes that information
can come
at any moment depending on what you've
done what's the occasion
i'll tell you over dessert
[Music]
all right i'm ready to get wowed by this
dessert just give me one second
[Music]
you know i are fascinated by the idea of
if you know what's going to happen what
would you do
differently
[Music]
12 minutes is an interactive thriller
about a man trapped in a time loop
you come home from work you're having an
evening with your wife then this is
this cop shows up he chooses your wife
of murder hands behind your back let's
go
you try to stop him you get beat up
only to wake up back to the start of the
evening
and then you have to use the knowledge
of what you know it's going to happen
to try to change the outcome and break
the loop look
i know this sounds weird but the day's
repeating itself
what do you mean repeating itself i'm
living the same chunk of time
over and over again
the reason the game sticks to a bird's
eye view is because it allows you
to very easily interact with the
environment most video games you have
a third person camera or a first person
camera and i wanted to create something
that is
very accessible so by doing a bird's-eye
view you have like a floor plan
of the apartment that you just click
with the room
there was also the challenge of having
the voices convey the emotions without
seeing the faces
if someone is really stressed out you
won't have any facial expressions so you
have to feel the stress in the throat
particularly because you don't see our
faces in it you really are projecting
whatever you're feeling onto the
character there's no facial expressions
that are instructing you
where you go in the game will i think
depend on you as an an
individual i just need some time to
myself
come on babe please stop it
and if there's enough subtlety in the
voice acting in the movement your brain
will feel the rest
because actors think in terms of
motivations you know what's my
motivation for this thing
and workshopping with them figuring
those things out allows
the characters to become alive and
become meaningful in the way they
they behave like i didn't mean to this
is never what i wanted
no come on i warned you look i you can't
do this it will be different things for
different people
there are so many versions of the story
that will either reveal something or
show something
and you as the player are revealing how
you deal with truth how you deal with
other people's truth
working in interactive medium you can
make a story that becomes very personal
to you
right you're not passively looking at
what's happening and processing you're
actually
deciding by allowing you to participate
to change it
to mold the way it's built in a way it
becomes part of you it's like you're
part of the creative process that is
happening
and because the game doesn't really give
you a direction the decisions you make
are based on who you are
i'll prove it yeah great let's see it
wow me that allows you to
explore a site of yourself that maybe
you wouldn't otherwise
[Music]
silently repeat these phrases
may you be free from suffering may you
be
free from fear may you know
peace and joy
[Music]
you